[Musica]
terra terra è sicuramente una parola che
è il marinaio navigatori nominavano
quando finalmente intravedevano la loro
destinazione ma certamente alcuni di
loro hanno scoperto qualche nuova terra
terra è un po come dire eureka e ho
trovato ho trovato qualcosa di nuovo è
un'aspirazione umana classica semplice
quella di ricercare e scoprire nuove
terno rimondi nuove teoria è sotto
queste terre questi mondi c'è sempre
un'idea un'intuizione sicuramente
interessante è l'intuizione che portò
cristoforo colombo a scoprire il nuovo
continente in realtà lui non lo sapeva
lui voleva andare in india da occidente
anziché da est e quindi si ritrovò ad
andare a cuba è in realtà pensava di
essere in india
come dire a volte può succedere però
nulla toglie a colombo come dire la
maestosità della sua scoperta del
coraggio per lo meno di quell intuizione
che poi ha davvero cambiato o un'epoca a
questa storia se ne leggo un'altra in
realtà e popolare non ha un fondamento
ma quella dell'uovo di colombo è un po
una metafora per dire che a volte nella
vita delle idee abbastanza semplici sono
capaci di risolvere dei problemi enormi
o addirittura impossibili come andò la
storia colombo era diventato ormai
famoso il cardinal mendoza che come
avete visto in un commento
il suo amico lo invito a casa ea cena è
durante la cena tutti avevano modo di ri
dire che chiunque avrebbe potuto
compiere l'impresa di colombo con gli
stessi fondi perché colombo da bravo
start upper andò a chiedere un po in
giro dei finanziamenti per la sua
impresa è ovviamente lui un pò stufo un
pò stanco sfidò tutti gli ospiti e disse
sai che provate a tenere in piedi un
nuovo sul tavolo impossibile tutti ci
provavano nessuno ci riusciva lui prese
il nuovo l'ho picchiato
sull'angolo del tavolo e lo posiziona in
piedi e tutti di chiuse roba
e ci vuole lo potevamo fare anche noi
lui disse certo lo potevate fare anche
voi ma io l'ho fatto per primo è quindi
come dire epicwin ora a me questa
metafora piace particolarmente perché
perché effettivamente l'uovo di colombo
è un po quell idea che tutti ricerchiamo
e io l'ho messo in qualcosa che reputavo
abbastanza serio promessa sulla
copertina così capita che è vero io ho
fatto una tesi di laurea in economia
industriale basata su una idea piuttosto
semplice prendiamo un panzerotto è
proviamo a portarlo in una formula che
cola del fast food cioè vado in cassa
pago come al mcdonald come in un
qualunque altro fast food del mondo e
ricevo questo prodotto perché qualcosa
di così buono non dovrebbe funzionare
così bene soprattutto perché poi era un
po l'idea alla base
questo mercato è davvero grande davvero
ricco mantiene testa e profittabilità
anche nei periodi di crisi perché il
fast food e tendenzialmente più
affordable più accessibile ma non vede
the player italiani sia da un punto di
vista degli item dei prodotti e sia da
un punto di vista dell'impresa
effettivamente se andiamo a guardare
quella che è la distribuzione di
migliori player all'interno di questo
mercato non troviamo imprese italiane
anche quando il prodotto è italiano il
che ovviamente significa che questa
intuizione e giusta magari posso provare
a conquistare il mondo con un panzerotto
una polpetta un pezzo di focaccia ma in
realtà potrebbe essere che non basta
prendere qualcosa che siamo abituati a
consumare qui portarlo altrove è fare il
botto come magari qualcun altro ha fatto
tante che per inverso anche un gigante
in realtà ha avuto qualche piccolo
problema altamura puglia mcdonald apre
2001 è costretto dopo qualche mese a
chiudere la gente andava a comprarsi la
focaccia da un'altra parte e se la
mangia va dentro il mcdonald che era
climatici
ora il punto è che effettivamente questa
cosa mi fece pensare se loro con quell
idea erano riusciti a fallire qui ma
perché non avrei potuto fare lo stesso
errore io andando altrove
quindi il take out di quell esperienza
fu che effettivamente o che l'idea era
carina e la simpatica ma quello che
rende un'idea di successo oltre
all'intuizione e anche l'esecuzione e il
modo in cui o quelli della realizzo e il
modo in cui io riesco a prendere
quell'intuizione trasformarle in una
realtà che funziona e che nel caso di un
imprese profittevole al che da buon
universitario di simile e ho imparato
qualcosa se un giorno troverò questo
uovo di colombo sicuramente dovrò
partire dalla puglia perché se funziona
qui allora funziona ovunque nel mondo
dopo di che da bravo start upper non mi
sono fatto finanziare ma ho convinto mia
madre a spostare la legna per fare un
agenzia e con altri quattro scalmanati
ci siamo dati a quello che è il
marketing del 2012
iniziamo a lavorare cresciamo
incontriamo un cliente un commerciante
ittico che organizzava già da due anni
un evento una festa del pesce con una
rievocazione storica del palio del mare
un evento fantastico in cui si poteva
appunto gustare in una formula del tutto
destrutturata a crudo mare frittura
panini a base di polpo e così via è
godersi lo spettacolo del palio qualcosa
di davvero molto bello ma anche a
qualcosa che ci porta a un certo punto
sulle ali dell'entusiasmo a dire dai
dobbiamo aprirci un fish barchi in
realtà nessuno pensava che dovevamo
andare a sfidare è chi sa un colosso che
il mercato italiano
semplicemente avevamo un'idea prendiamo
il prodotto quello che appunto il mio
attuale socio continua a consegnare nei
migliori ristoranti della puglia è lo
portiamo in un fish bar lo serviamo come
se fosse un panino del mcdonald's ma i
dentro ci mettiamo quello che noi
pugliesi siamo abituati a mangiare il
pesce crudo
bell'idea bella intuizione ma bastava
per garantire un esecuzione
secondo noi no così totalmente folli
solo a 30 giorni dall apertura ci
diciamo bene dovremmo trovare
sicuramente uno chef è lui che ci
dovrebbe aiutare a fare una migliore
esecuzione di questa idea e lì arrivano
a quella che è stata poi un po l'imprint
della della nostra esecuzione della
nostra idea di fast food di qualità
privato al prodotto ittico pugliese
quello che poche volte ho raccontato è
che in realtà nessuno aveva pensato fino
a 5 giorni prima di mettere quello che
poi si è rivelato essere il nostro uovo
di colombo cioè il panino con dentro il
pesce crudo il fattore scatenante che
effettivamente ha dato a questa idea una
via del tutto inaspettata è che ci ha
portato effettivamente ad essere un
diciamo punto di riferimento per lo meno
un fenomeno che non solo in puglia ma
anche altrove ha avuto un suo
interessante riscontro
ovviamente come nel caso di cristoforo
colombo anche nel nostro caso noi
veniamo spesso reputati fortunati come
dire non sono quasi mai contrario a
addossarmi il ruolo di persona fortunata
anche perché sono convinto di una cosa
la fortuna è un animo pronto che
incontra una buona occasione è un'anima
pronto un animo che ha delle intuizioni
le mette alla prova non si accontenta le
migliora le evolve e le trasforma fino
al punto di renderle un problema che di
renderli una soluzione che per quanto
semplice e capace di risolvere anche un
problema impossibile come quello magari
di provare a scalfire delle piccole
quote di mercato
all'interno di un mercato dove noi
italiani c'è da dire non diciamo tanto
la nostra io quindi vi auguro di essere
fortunati vi auguro sicuramente di avere
delle buone intuizioni e perché no vi
auguro di trovare il vostro uovo di
colombo buona continuazione
[Applauso]